the modern left has managed to redefine
the term prostitution and now instead of
calling prostitutes prostitutes we're
supposed to call them sex workers the
idea is to Rebrand prostitution as
something other than the morally
depraved reprehensible conduct that no
civilized society should ever tolerate
much less embrace and as you might
expect many media Outlets including the
New York Times are on board with this
change in terminology they're pushing it
promoting it actually the paper of
record recently ran a whole op-ed about
the importance of meeting the needs of
sex workers according to the piece we
need to end the social stigma
surrounding sex work CBS news for its
part has run several sympathetic stories
about policies that can quote legitimize
the industry of sex work
now given all that it's with great
interest that I checked out the websites
of both the New York Times and CBS news
last night to see how they were covering
the story of a Virginia State House
candidate named Susanna Gibson Gibson as
you may have heard was just outed as a
cyber prostitute a porn star she live
streamed videos on a porn website of
herself engaging in various sex acts
with her husband in exchange for money
from strangers otherwise known as
prostitution
she even offered at 1.2 urinate for
viewers if they if they paid up and to
be clear Gibson's husband was of course
well aware that all this was happening
in fact he solicited donations at
various points
um and these were not private videos
they were not password protected uh they
weren't videos that were just on their
laptops and a hacker went in and stole
them and put them online uh no anyone
could access them
and without going into too much detail
people could obtain even more salacious
footage if they threw money at Gibson in
the form of uh what was called tokens on
the website
Gibson assured her audience that the
money was going to a quote good cause
which perhaps was her political campaign
we don't know now if the New York Times
and CBS News truly meant what they've
been saying all these years about the
legitimacy of sex work about the fact
that it's an admirable uh occupation
that should not be stigmatized you'd
think that this would be the easiest
imaginable story for them to cover here
you have a strong independent woman
engaging in consensual acts of
prostitution with a willing partner what
could be more liberating than that
truly this is what decades of feminism
have been leading to all along this is
the ultimate feminist success story
a sex worker becomes a politician which
is really more of a lateral move I guess
you're going from one form of
prostitution to another uh but you know
it's the new American Dream
except strangely enough that's not how
these Outlets are covering this story
instead of Defending Susanna Gibson's
conduct both the New York Times and CBS
News are lying about it
they're denying it
and these are not subtle lies I mean
these are as obvious and lazy as they
can possibly be the times decided to
ignore the facts of the whole situation
and instead reported that Gibson's
videos had been leaked
so this was their headline quote State
House candidate in Virginia condemns
leak of sex tapes
now what they're doing is hiding the
fact that Gibson uploaded the footage
herself
they're implying that someone else
leaked these videos that someone
secretly went in and and obtained them
and then distributed them to the public
which is not what happened at all and
they know that
Fred's part CBS News ran this headline
quote Virginia election candidate
responds after a leak of tapes showings
shows her performing sex acts with
husband
now below that headline CBS News copy
pasted inaccurate Associated Press
article describing what actually
happened so CBS news's only contribution
to the story was adding an obviously
false headline to mislead as many people
as possible uh under the assumption that
most people wouldn't actually read the
article and of course most people don't
now this is all more than a little
strange I mean here you have a perfect
opportunity for both of these Outlets
the New York Times and CBS news to
report honestly on the sex work that
Susanna Gibson was engaging in
that shouldn't be a big deal because as
these organizations have established sex
work is as Noble as any other form of
work sex work is real work they say
but instead of doing that they're lying
about the basic facts of the story
they're pretending that Gibson wasn't
selling pornographic videos for money
instead they're pushing the lie that she
was hacked that her private videos
somehow found their way on the internet
when in fact again they found their way
on the internet because Gibson put them
there on purpose
to make money off of them
in case you're keeping track these are
the same Outlets that went wall-to-wall
on Donald Trump's so-called p-tape which
didn't exist by the way
now they're telling you that you're not
allowed to discuss a Democratic party
candidate's actual p-tape which she
uploaded on the internet
I think the word brazen doesn't even
begin to describe this
but it gets even more brazen Susanna
Gibson herself has gone even further
than these outlets and she claims that
she is now the victim of a sex crime
because people are talking about videos
that she put on the internet she is now
a sex crime victim
watch
a Virginia Democratic candidate is
getting caught up in a porn Scandal
before her campaign can even begin
Susanna Gibson is claiming the release
of videos showing her and her husband
performing sexual acts live on a
streaming site is an invasion of privacy
Gibson and her husband asked for tips
while performing sex acts for a live
audience on shatterbait she was quote
raising money for a good cause it is
unclear when the live streams occurred
Gibson who is running one of Virginia's
seven highly contested house races said
in a statement the leaks of the online
activity were quote the worst gutter
politics and an illegal invasion of my
privacy designed to humiliate me and my
family Gibson's lawyer said the release
of the videos is a violation of
Virginia's revenge porn law making it a
Class one misdemeanor to maliciously
distribute nude or sexual images with
the intent to coerce harass or
intimidate Gibson is facing Republican
David Owen for the house seat and the
state's 57th District which is outside
of Richmond and primarily in Henrico
County it is one of the seven toss-up
seats in the hundred member house
now you notice you know I get in trouble
all the time for things that I post on
the internet which are not sex tapes but
you know like tweets I'll tweet
something and then people get very upset
about it and many times the the tweets
are being misconstrued deliberately and
so I'll object to that but what I never
do is is claim that you're invading my
privacy by talking about tweets that I
have myself written and and published on
the internet I see I never do that
because it doesn't make any sense
now let's think about this for a second
Susanna Gibson voluntarily uploads
footage of herself having sex with her
husband with her husband's consent
obviously to a porn website she and her
husband both solicit money from
Anonymous viewers on this website in
return they promise to engage in even
more sex acts none of this is occurring
on some private Channel anyone with a
working internet connection can see it
some of these acts by the way were
broadcast after Gibson announced a run
for office in Virginia and now Gibson
tells us it's a sex crime to share this
footage it violates Virginia's revenge
porn laws if that's true or ironically
enough if that's true it would mean that
Susannah Gibson and her husband are the
ones guilty of sex crimes because
they're the ones who shared the footage
so they have committed sex crimes
against themselves
throw them in prison then I guess
September as you probably already know
is National fruits and veggies month
balance of nature of fruits and veggies
are a great way to make sure that you're
getting essential nutritional
ingredients every single day through
balance of Nature's Advanced cold vacuum
process the vitamins minerals and
phytonutrients of the fruits and
vegetables are preserved so that you can
get that vital nutrition in each capsule
balance of nature is a whole food
supplement with no additives fillers
extracts synthetics pesticides or added
sugar pure fruits and veggies are the
only thing they put in their capsules
balance of nature sent a bunch of their
products down to the studio for my team
to try we all love them when you're
disciplined enough to take care of your
health you reap all kinds of benefits
and your body will thank you for it so
go to balanceofnature.com use promo code
Walsh for 30.5 off your first order as a
preferred customer that's
balanceofnature.com promo code Walsh for
35 off your first preferred order most
people only think about poor air quality
when we have fires like the ones that
just happened in Canada causing New York
to be a strange orange color that made
the air quality absolutely terrible but
if you stop to think about the polluted
air in your day-to-day life if you and
your family's health may be affected by
the air quality in your home allergens
and germs floating in the air can can
make you sick but the good news is that
there's technology out there that helps
you purify your living space easily and
affordable with enviral cleanse you'll
never have to worry again Enviro cleanse
is an in-home air purifying unit
designed to destroy cold and flu viruses
allergy inflaming toxins mold and even
more Enviro cleanse promises far fewer
colds allergies and also better sleep
their air purifiers come in all sizes
colors and prices to fit every budget
and they offer additional products like
Surface Cleaner and laundry detergent as
well in viral cleanse is the air
purifier we use in our home works great
gives me the peace of mind that I'm
breathing in healthy air and the last
thing our family needs is to get sick
Enviro cleanse offers a simple solution
for keeping me healthy and all the
family healthy and in Tip-Top shape
breathe in pure air and live a healthier
life visit ekpure.com use code Walsh for
10 off your Enviro cleanse home air
purification unit right now you'll also
get their free air quality monitor Plus
fast free shipping that's 150 savings
ekpure.com code Walsh that's ekpure.com
promo code Walsh
uh so it's not just a facile argument
that we're talking about here it's
completely and totally absurd it's the
kind of argument you make when you're
ashamed of what you've done and you know
there's no defense for it so you blurt
out the first thing that comes to mind I
mean saying that it's a sex crime for
people to share a sex tape that you
published on the Internet it's like
selling your car to someone and then as
soon as they're driving away calling the
police and claiming that you're a victim
of Grand Theft Auto
or perhaps you remember when Anthony
Weiner claimed that he was hacked
because he had no defense for why he was
sending pictures of his crotch to random
women on the internet it's a bit like
that as well
the level of desperation
is really something to behold they're so
desperate that they're co-opting the
same terminology they told us was sacred
the language of the metoo movement as a
political cover for behavior that they
know is repulsive
they're saying we're all sex criminals
for noticing what they're uploading on
the internet
which which is not simply hypocrisy
these are the panicked cries of
feminists who are afraid to confront The
Logical endpoint of their entire
movement which is that feminism doesn't
actually liberate women from anything
instead it encourages them to become
slaves to their most degenerate base
sexual desires
a great illustration of this hypocrisy
comes to us from the feminist blog
Jezebel Jezebel like the New York Times
and CBS News is currently claiming that
Republicans are demonizing Gibson for
the crime of having sex with her husband
that's the straw man they're running
with as unsurprising and predictable as
it may be and Jezebel of course repeats
the line that even talking about
Gibson's videos might amount to a sex
crime
what's especially interesting about
Jezebel's coverage though is that they
just ran a long post about the personal
life of presidential candidate Tim Scott
saying that he needs to be more open
about why he doesn't have a girlfriend
at the age of 57 or I guess he claims he
does have a girlfriend so why isn't he
married at the age of 57 the piece mocks
Scott for allegedly being a virgin until
he was middle-aged it also suggests that
he's suffering from marriage-related
trauma from his upbringing after his
father a Vietnam War veteran developed a
drinking problem so
the progressive feminists at Jezebel are
allowed to mock Tim Scott for all of
these personal issues which are actually
personal and they haven't even remotely
verified
but at the same time Jezebel also says
you can't talk about multiple sex tapes
that a woman running for office in the
Democrat Party published for public
consumption
and there's a lot of this on the
internet right now the same media
Outlets saying that we we should respect
Susanna Gibson's privacy
even though she didn't respect her own
privacy
are also reporting incessantly about
their speculations about Tim Scott's
private life
now to be clear
um some questions about Scott's personal
life are legitimate he seems very much
to be lying about having a girlfriend
who he refuses to identify in any way it
does sound a bit like he's pulling the
old my girlfriend goes to another school
move and if we're being honest it's
weird to have a 57 year old Bachelor
running for president but at the same
time there's an obvious double standard
in the way the media treats questions
about a politician's private life
depending on their political party
another example is the incessant
reporting on the whereabouts of Melania
Trump who's been absent from the
campaign Trail uh I mean we really
haven't seen her at all on at Donald
Trump's side whether it's at rallies or
you know when he's showing up for these
Court appearances and again I think
objectively
those are perfectly valid questions but
by the same token once we allow for all
that that it's clear that a political
candidate's history as a porn star is
also very relevant
now there's a reason the left is denying
this and it has nothing to do with one
state level candidate in Virginia
they're lying about what Susanna Gibson
did because her behavior highlights a
very uncomfortable truth about the great
experiment the left has conducted for so
many years the truth is this after
multiple waves and generations of
feminism which supposedly were all about
treating women like people instead of
objects that's how it was sold anyway uh
pornography has now become so normalized
and mainstreamed in our society that we
have a bunch of soccer moms whoring
themselves out on the internet for a few
extra bucks
these are not young girls getting sex
trafficked or turning to Street
prostitution out of desperation these
are bored middle class women with loose
morals looking for validation and a
little extra spending cash
you know I've talked many times about
what I call the trajectory of leftism
and with any item on their agenda
anything they promote
it always starts and ends the same way
so first they deny that they're doing
the thing then they admit they're doing
it but they insist that it's good and
then they say that since it's good it
should actually be celebrated and
finally they invite or demand that we
participate
so we go from a denial to promotion to
Celebration to participation
and now we see that pornography has
followed this same path and we have
finally arrived at the participation
stage where where the problem becomes
terminal first they denied that they
wanted to make hardcore porn mainstream
and accessible to everyone including
children and then he said that uh well
actually porn is good and it should be
mainstream
and then they demanded that we celebrate
uh these porn stars and cyber
prostitutes and their free expression
and now porn has been opened up for all
to actively participate in it
which is an invitation that many
attention-starved women like Susannah
Gibson have responded to
the problem
one of the many many problems
is that selling your body to random
creeps online is depressing and despair
inducing and soul crushing
eventually these women all get sick of
it and they want to move on
and understandably so but there is no
moving on in the internet age everything
you've done there
you do forever it lives on whether you
like it or not
and that does not make you a victim or
give you the right to cry about
invasions of privacy
it just means you need to make better
choices
as Susannah Gibson and many women like
her have now discovered the hard way if
you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed